this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you all for being here today
I'm excited to talk about what I've been
doing the past two years it's definitely
flown by so just as an introduction to
this topic Don mentioned that I had
spent some time at the Birmingham
botanical gardens and working in their
native plant collection I really develop
some interests that were instrumental in
developing this topic public gardens
addressing environmental issues through
the use of native plants
so native plants have existed for
millennia have evolved with their
environments and have become
increasingly popular in the cultivated
landscape for the purposes of this
research a native plant is one that
occurs naturally in a particular region
state ecosystem inhabit without direct
or indirect human action and to provide
a context for this study I am studying
native plants in public gardens which
are living museums mission based
institutions which maintain plant
collections and plant records by a
professional staff and are open to the
public the study of native plants are
important to Botanical Gardens because
they serve missions including displaying
biodiversity beauty and history
so when I began this study I started
questioning why native plants were
increasing in use and one of my
observation was that they were being
used to address environmental issues
such as food for wildlife a reduction in
the use of chemical pesticides
fertilizers and water when planted in
their natural habitats preventing the
spread of alien invasive plants
contributing to fido remediation efforts
addressing climate change and increasing
ecosystem biodiversity they also are
valued for their aesthetic beauty and
regional sense of place my research
objectives for this study are to
understand how public gardens are using
native plants throughout their gardens
and program offerings what the
motivations are for doing so and if they
are addressing environmental issues
native plants are supported by research
but I wanted to know what motivates
public gardens for using them so I chose
for us botanical gardens based on
preliminary interviews their prominence
in the field and their collections
policies I conducted 223 phone
interviews to maintain consistency with
leadership staff of each garden
including the executive director
director of horticulture and director of
education when applicable these
interviews were followed up by site
visits when I had previously if I had
previously not visited the garden and I
conducted follow-up interviews based on
the need in the writing process so now
I'm just going to go through each site
first night was the lady bird johnson
wildflower center which is located in
austin texas and it was created through
the vision of Lady Bird Johnson and
actress Helen Hayes their mission serves
to focus their displays in education
around native plants of the state of
Texas
the second site is New England
wildflower society's living museum
garden in the woods it was founded and
designed by will Curtis and they display
native plants of the New England region
education at Garden in the woods centers
around engaging visitors to gain an
interest in using native plants the
third site was the bledel reserve
located on Bainbridge Island Washington
it was created through the inspiration
of prentice bloedel and his wife with
the mission of providing a tranquil
visitor experience this series of
landscape spans over 150 acres and is
picturesque of the Pacific Northwest the
final site was the Birmingham Botanical
Gardens which is unique to this study
and it offers a variety of collections
for visitors to experience including two
gardens of nature which focus on the
display and education of native plants
the collections were made possible by
donations of money and volunteer hours
by key individuals so now I'll tell you
a little bit about what I found in the
form of key themes differences
challenges successes and practical
implications from the study
so the first theme was the use of native
plants throughout the gardens and
program areas as pictured here native
plants permeate throughout the education
and displays at the wildflower center
and at Garden in the woods while their
styles vary at both of these gardens
teaching people to understand appreciate
and use the regional native flora is in
a sustainable manner is central to the
organizational goals the use of native
plants that the bledel reserve is
focused on providing a tranquil
experience currently they do not have a
formal education program at the
birmingham botanical gardens native
plants are displayed in two areas
focusing on the biodiversity the state
has to offer the Barbara Alabama
Woodlands displays mainly native trees
and serves as a hub of native plant
education for children the call
wildflower garden was developed from an
old stone quarry from the works progress
progress administration and is pictured
here and displays our basis native
plants placing a special focus on those
of wild provenance in Alabama while
native plants are not central to their
mission at the Birmingham Botanical
Gardens they do offer educational
programming for all ages that encourages
a deeper engagement with native plants a
second theme was the motivation behind
the use of native plants key figures
played a role in establishing each
garden or collection within the garden
in each case of this study beyond that
the key figures Lady Bird Johnson will
Curtis and Prentiss bledel respectively
at the wildflower center garden in the
woods and the bloedel reserve were all
influential in establishing a mission
that was instrumental in determining the
plant collections policies at these
gardens
a third theme was the motivation for
using native plants for environmental
purposes each garden in this study
emphasized using native plants for a
conservation purpose thus promoting an
awareness and in the case of why the
Wildflower Center and garden in the
woods the use and further conservation
of native plants garden in the woods
further has a display of rare and
endangered native plants gardens also
display native plants in order to
enhance their natural world so as to
bridge visitors to it a couple of
examples are public gardens providing a
place for visitors to see the effects of
climate change on plants and to see
solutions on how to address this issue
in the same way they are using native
plants and their natural habitats to
illustrate the reduction of water and
chemical inputs
some collections at the Wildflower
Center and guard in the woods
specifically were established to address
environmental issues through their
research efforts research areas included
native plant propagation carbon
sequestration with native grasses of
Texas green roof composition alternative
turf mixes water runoff and others in
the future each garden in the study is
increasing efforts to reduce their
environmental impact another trend that
arose in this study was the focus of
reaching three specific audience groups
professionals in the Lance in landscape
architecture architecture design and
contracting young families and singles
in their 20s and 30s by creating various
educational programs workshops and
garden events towards these different
groups they hope to garner the interest
and further their missions
there were two key differences between
the gardens in this study the first
difference was the specific
environmental issues that were addressed
because each garden resides in a
different climate zone in the u.s. each
garden focuses on a different issue for
example the blue del Reserve in
Washington State enjoys regular rainfall
however they are continually focused on
maintaining clean water sources the
Wildflower Center in Central Texas
places a major focus on water
conservation as they constantly face
drought another major difference was in
the educational programs offered the
blue del reserve was the only garden in
the study lacking a formal education
program although they do offer informal
programs such as walks and tours
education is completely focused on
native plants at the Wildflower Center
and garden in the woods and recently the
Birmingham Botanical Gardens joined in
efforts as all three of these gardens
offer a native plant certificate program
these certificates are awarded to
participants through their completion of
required and elective courses field
trips and volunteer service
each garden also experience exceptional
success in various ways of using native
plants the three pictured here are ways
that gardens are disseminating
information on native plants the native
plant database on the wildflower
Center's website is internationally
access and in last year alone received 5
million hits the recently launched
certificate in native plant studies at
the Birmingham Botanical Gardens has had
an overwhelming success in that their
response rate and that they have had to
create more classroom space to meet the
demand and they have enjoyed an
unexpected revenue generated the recent
launch of new england wildflower
society's go botany program a computer
but is a computer based program that is
used to facilitate education and
displays in a variety of settings and
according to staff is in high demand
success of the bloedel reserve comes in
the form of grant funding for
restoration programs which have
continually increased over the past two
and a half years staff members also know
that an anecdotal feedback from visitors
the key each garden also faces
challenges that affect their displays in
educational efforts of native plants one
of these is managing invasive plants
today 1.4 trillion dollars or five
percent of the global economy is spent
managing invasive species while
historically public gardens may have
played a role in bringing invasive
plants in through plant exploration they
are recognizing their damaging effects
and costs associated with them are
working to prevent their future
developments other challenges included
caring for a large space with limited
staff and budgets and overcoming the
general lack of knowledge of the value
and importance of native plants yes yes
that's a pretty picture to look at thank
you for pointing that up using native
plants in public gardens as presented in
this study culminates into a group of
practical implications these are
intended to build the success of other
gardens use of native plants and how
they use them to address environmental
issues these include establishing
expected outcomes in their use using
them in a way that continues the design
of the garden using their connection
with native with animals to bring in
younger audiences using them throughout
the collection instead of in individual
collections considering the
environmental effects of the design
process and to look at other
organizations for guides as creating
successful displays and educational
programs
I conducted this study this is to
discover how public gardens are using
native plants and if a main motivation
is to address environmental issues I
found that these gardens are using
native plants in diverse ways to not
only address environmental issues but
also to demonstrate that their value
goes beyond their positive environmental
roles these gardens are able to display
their beauty encouraging and
understanding and appreciation of native
plants and thus furthering their use so
I'd like to acknowledge my committee and
Cornell plantations for funding and
support throughout the process and the
other fellows in the program
yes places you visited express a
challenge of sourcing their native
plants which is propagating them or
finding the flyer and how do they
address that
um no they didn't because all gardens
have their own nurseries that it it
really didn't come up but I think
they're all some of them are wild
collecting seeds and I know it didn't
come up in the interviews at all
actually I think they're trying to
actually provide sources for people in
their communities that do have
challenges with that
yes done both bloedel reserve and the
Birmingham Botanical Gardens where it's
a mixture of new plant explains and
non-natives are the horticulturist
taking measures in the non-native
displays to make sure that they're not
introducing in vases that could migrate
into the native displays
I think that where that comes up is more
at the Birmingham Botanical Gardens the
barber Alabama woodlands that I
mentioned is probably 20 feet from their
Japanese garden and the Japanese garden
does have invasive plants so they are
constantly trying to pull those out and
that is something that they just
recognized as a challenge and it's
something that they have to do at the
Bedell reserve because everything grows
so fast invasives are always a major
challenge and the restoration programs
that they are implementing are really
helping to address that does that answer
your question yeah I know
did you get any response from the
um I think they are they're not sensing
the pressure but they are wanting to
reach out the groups so these
certificate programs that three of the
gardens have they are really trying to
reach people in the industries like
landscape architecture the to encourage
green building practices and establish
between plants and the correct habitats
so I I think it's the pressure is more
than reaching out to people and not
they're not getting that from people
outside that makes sense yes
so I think a lot of the gardens in the
study have seen the growth but they
haven't specifically been tracking it
and that is something that I recommend
for future research to really see what
the impacts are in numbers
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu